jetzt sprechen wir über einen schlechten
scherz oder können manche aktivisten
diesen satz von klimaschützern luisa
neubauer auch als noch zur gewalt
verstehen das hat sie gesagt wenn sie
mal rein
ja natürlich denken wir darüber nach wie
wir die pipeline in die luft jagen
können leser neubauer und im hintergrund
ihren mitstreiter lachen terror witze
auf einem demokratie gipfeln ja gesagt
hat sie das nämlich beim kopenhagen
democracy es damit in dänemark
eigentlich diskutieren dort politiker
aktivisten und geschäftsleute über die
zukunft der demokratie
dann werden natürlich nachgefragt bei
luisa neubauer was sie damit meint aber
sie nahmen nur zur pipeline selbst
stellung nicht aber zu ihren
formulierungen bezüglich einer sprengung
derselben das hat sie uns gesagt das
projekt allein würde fast ein halbe
gigatonnen co2 produzieren daher
arbeiten wir seit monaten zusammen mit
aktivistinnen aus der region also uganda
und tansania und auch mit vielen
menschen aus frankreich gegen die
pipeline die der französische konzern
total bauen möchte also dort erst mal
nur ein statement das inhaltlich ja
etwas wieder gibt aber es ist eben noch
nicht klar was sie eigentlich mit diesem
satz meint hören wir also noch mal rein
luisa neubauer das ist ja das deutsche
gesicht von freies for future sozusagen
die deutsche greta thunberg nur etwas
älter ist die schwedische kollegin die
deutschen klimaschutz aktivistin ist
eine der deutschen hauptorganisatorinnen
der klima streiks friday futures
außerdem mitglied bei den grünen und der
grünen jugend und engagiert sich in ganz
verschiedenen
nichtregierungsorganisationen
und jetzt dieser satz ausgerechnet von
ihr dem gesicht und freitags verschafft
das video mit dem terror willst das
stellte sie sogar selbst ins internet
die pipeline um die es hier geht die
heißt übrigens east african crude oil
pipeline also aus afrikanische rohöl
pipeline wir schon mal rein in das
gesamte video von luisa neubauer
jetzt gerade planen wir wie wir eine
pipeline in die luft jagen können
wir reden über die co pipeline die
größte öl pipeline der welt die in
ostafrika gebaut wird und wir werden sie
stoppen er darüber spricht heute
natürlich deutschland so ein satz von
einer jungen frau die natürlich auch
ganz viele follower hatten jetzt hat sie
sich auch auf twitter geäußert und
schreibt jesus maria es ist nur ein buch
das ist das buch über das sie spricht
how to blow up pipeline ja das ist ein
buch eines radikalen schwedischen
klimaaktivisten namens andreas meyer und
in diesem buch ruft er dazu auf
sachbeschädigungen und sabotagen an
industrieanlagen zu begehen um den
klimawandel voran zu bringen
gewalt gegen suvs und kohleminen hält
man in diesem buch völlig für
gerechtfertigt den klimawandel stoppen
ja aber doch nicht mit gewalt und wir
sind jetzt verbunden mit christoph ploß
von der unionsfraktion im bundestag
auch sie haben diese story gesehen was
halten sie davon ist es ein aufruf zur
gewalt zu terrorismus vielleicht sogar
schon
also ich würde jetzt nicht luisa
neubaus legen wollen dass sie dazu
terroristischen attentaten aufrufen
möchte das würde so weit gehen aber sie
hat sich der brust sein dass sie
zumindest andere leute dazu verleiten
kann denn wir erleben ja in der klima
szene oder bei einigen selbst ändern
klimaschützern dass diese sich zunehmend
radikalisieren das auch in teile klima
szene immer offen dazu gewalt aufgerufen
wird und diese leute fühlen sich durch
solche statements
möglicherweise noch motiviert genau dann
auch die gewaltspirale weiter eskalieren
zu lassen und deswegen muss sich luisa
neubauer entschuldigen und sie muss
klarstellen dass das ein großer fehler
war ansonsten ist die gefahr groß dass
es einen schaden für unsere gesellschaft
gibt sie hat natürlich das muss man dazu
sagen auch reagierte die story
inzwischen gelöscht und hat darauf
aufmerksam gemacht dass dieses zitat von
einem buch kommt dennoch steht weiterhin
die frage im raum wie groß ist der
einfluss unsere quasi klima schützen
nummer 13 des for future eine riesige
bewegung vor allem auch sehr beliebt bei
vielen schülern bei vielen jugendlichen
wie groß ist ihr einfluss dort ist sie
sich diesen einfluss vielleicht auch gar
nicht so sehr bewusst
also sie hat natürlich einen enormen
einfluss gerade auf jüngere menschen in
unserem land und deswegen muss sie ihre
worte auch sehr sorgsam abwägen und
diese aussage werden möglicherweise
viele verstehen als aufruf zu gewalt
oder als aufruf selber gewalttätig zu
werden und selber möglicherweise sogar
irgendeine form von terrorismus zu
betreiben auch wenn wie gesagt ich dass
luisa neubauer auf keinen fall selber
unterstellen möchte und deswegen reicht
es aus meiner sicht nicht dass sie
einfach nur diesen post gelöscht hat
sondern sie muss sich öffentlich
entschuldigen und es reicht auch nicht
dass sie sagt na ja irgendwo kam ein
solches zitat in einem buch vor viele
werden dieses zitat missverstehen und
die gefahr die ich sehe ist dass durch
solche äußerungen öl ins feuer gegossen
wird und am ende möglicherweise eine
gewaltspirale
einsetzt die wir als gesellschaft
überhaupt nicht gebrauchen können das
was wir gerade bei den wichtigen thema
klimaschutz brauchen ist ja mehr
gesellschaftlicher zusammenhalt und eine
antwort auf die frage wie erreichen wir
die klimaschutzziele hinter der möglich
sehr viele in der bevölkerung stehen wir
werden mal sehen was dann noch kommt von
luisa neubauer westen dank herz für
diese einschätzung